To really understand objects and classes, it's best to work with lots of
examples. Let's try another example. And again, it's a great idea if you can do
this together with me. In BlueJ navigate to the pictures project in lesson two
and you will see here an icon representing a picture class. Let's make an
object of that class. Again, I will accept the default name, and here is my
object. What can I do with it? Well you know how to find that out. You right
click on the object and you get a list of things that tell you the methods.
Let's pick a method and in fact we will pick the method called pick. This
particular method opens up this file chooser here. That lists whatever image
files happen to be available. You can also navigate to other folders but we'll
just pick one here. Once you pick a file, a window pops up that shows the
image. Now let's see what else we can do. Let's call the pixels method. And it
tells me that this particular image has 104,976 pixels. Okay, that's
potentially interesting. over here we have method called translate. Let's just
play with it to see what it does. It wants two numbers. I will just put in 100
and 200, click on OK. And now look carefully at the planet. as you see, it
moved. So the method is not called translate because it doesn't translate this
into Lithuanian. Translation is a mathematical way of saying moving and it
moved it by 100 pixels in this direction and 200 pixels in that direction. So
this is another great example of an object. The object can do certain things.
The methods tell you what it can do. In the next exercise you get to play with
objects of the picture class.